[Music]
so today we're gonna talk about end
games we're gonna talk about three
specific end games then I'm gonna tell
you some general advice and then you'll
beat everybody in the end game right
okay and then when they ask you how do
you play the end game so well don't tell
them secret okay there's three endings
you should know this is the most
important you have a queen and your
opponent has nothing
so you're the favorite right you'll
probably win maybe okay yeah there you
go
why wouldn't you win a stalemate who can
raise their hand and correctly tell me
what stalemate is still me is nothing
can move you have no legal moves your
pawns can't move your Knights give what
nothing can move if nothing can move and
it's your turn and you're not in check
that's let's tell me when it's still me
who wins nobody so if this ended in a
stalemate which are probably what if you
guys were playing who would be happy
white or black black because black
should probably lose this position but
he didn't he got stalemated and white
should probably win so if white still
mates then White's not very happy either
and and when it's stalemate and nobody
wins how many points do you get you get
half a point okay so a stalemate is
better than getting checkmated and
checkmating somebody's better than still
meeting them so when you have a lot of
pieces and your opponent has just a king
don't stalemate them then you won't be
very happy okay
now I've seen a lot of this endgame and
a lot of people go check and then check
and then check and at some point both
kids start laughing okay that's is that
how you win this endgame no that's how
you laugh a lot but that's not how you
win at chess the way you win at chess
win this ending is you have to use your
King because you have two pieces and
your opponent has one piece and twos
better than
and if you move your queen every single
move that's just one against one and if
you don't use your king
you can't win it's impossible you need
your king to win the Queen by itself
can't checkmate yes Queen c5 is a good
move okay but I'm more interested in
move to move to is actually gonna be the
important move okay so here their King
is really far from our King so I move my
king closer and I always move my King
towards their King I don't care what the
position is I always do that I I need my
king you're their king and here
I can't move my king you're their king
because the computer won't let me so in
those instances you should buy a new
computer you could but I'm like the same
number of squares away like if I did
this there could be another there could
be more laughing going on and I've seen
this too I've seen this everybody starts
laughing and I'm like wow check reading
your opponents laugh after that okay
now sometimes my computer's broke in and
you know how I fix it the whole new
computer fixes it right up okay so here
okay so here I can't so I'm going to
play Queen here well I could play here
or here it doesn't matter okay now in a
position where a king is on a back row
and there's four back rows and if you're
in France the second highest rated
player in France is back row right it's
true yeah that's his name okay he's not
the best cuz he's back row so okay if
your King is on the back row and you
have the Queen you want your queen on
the next row because that way the King
can't leave right and some people said
chess players were squares right nothing
well that actually that's correct okay I
don't have it I can actually do yellow
about know how should I call Coldplay
yeah that was in yellow let's see this
right I give up okay I know what I'm
beat
okay so you want the King on the third
row and now we can do checkmate if it's
white
everything's check me it would be hard
not to check me you could do it but it's
tough this is checkmate this is check
this is check me and this is checkmate
that's a lot of checkmates
well it's blacks turn black moves this
King now there's only one checkmate okay
and when the Kings are lined up in a
straight line that's called opposition
that's good because you can checkmate
somebody when they're not lined up like
here and they're not lined up now I get
to put the Queen in front of the king
and actually I've seen a lot of kids put
their King in front of the King but I
need to buy a new computer to do that
because this computer won't let me
because that's not allowed I need a
computer doesn't know how to play chess
then I could do it okay
I've actually seen kids go here and say
check for me but that's not checkmate
okay so you're never allowed to have
your Kings touching now this is
checkmate because black has nowhere safe
to go okay and it's not stalemate
because the guys in check now if we if
we if we make a bad move you guys know
what I'm talking about
okay a bad move and now this is
checkmate so white wins and what's this
move called so it should white do that
no because then white doesn't win so
that's not good okay so you'd rather win
than that win yeah checkmate now now a
very common a very common thing that
happens is this this happens all the
time okay
this position is very common in chess
and then white makes a mistake and it's
stalemate and then both sides cry okay I
assume so remember what I told you when
they went well that's the wrong button
what's the right button is it this one
yeah so when the King is on the back row
you want your queen on the next row so
you can make a mistake here and play
King here which looks good but it's
stalemate so then you don't win so but
Queen here does what I said so that's
probably better okay and then you don't
stalemate in those situations now
you can chase the king which takes a
long time okay you can chase the king
all the way to the corner or if you want
to do it more quickly because you got a
bus to catch
okay instead of chasing the king you can
make the king come to you so the king is
running away you could make him one
swords your king that's better right
okay so he wants to go here he wants to
go here or in some instances here so you
play Queen here and he can't do that
yeah then you have to go this way and
then and then you can go checkmate or if
you don't like that checkmate you can do
this one maybe like that one
okay and when you checkmate a king with
a king and queen or king and rook which
is next the King has to be on a back row
if the black if the opposing King isn't
there there's no no checkmate exists
once the king is there you keep them
there so a very simple example I'm gonna
I'm gonna cheat a little bit and just do
this okay that was good cheating okay if
you're white in this position it's your
turn to move you already have the King
on the back row should we let black
escape the back row no so we should
either go Queen here Queen here or Queen
here they're all good I would go here
myself but okay and then then he would
go back and forth not very much to do
now if I was black I would go off the
board but I'm a grandmaster so you guys
can't do that okay even the computer
can't do it look truck okay and then and
then everything's checkmate
check checkmate checkmate everywhere
yeah everything's checkmate
okay now this checkmate is always check
mate with a queen but it's never checked
me with a ruck if that was a rook the
king could move sideways so if this was
a rook the only checkmate is this one
because rooks can't move diagonal so
that would be and if a rook is on the
side and the Kings are in opposition
that's that's checkmate okay and Queens
actually pretty easy to checkmate with
the problem is it's also
easy to stalemate with if you have a
king and a rook against the king it's
actually hard to steal me you don't have
to worry as much here you have to worry
because you might still meet your
opponent and then you don't win yes did
you raise your hand I missed it yeah you
it is almost him I can do it but I don't
like to okay so let's see I do this No
and then we'll make this a rook
okay and it's Richard Nixon once said I
am NOT a ruck so he's not a rook okay
now in this position if that was a queen
you would go Queen here checkmate and
that's it but it's a rug so you can't do
that because then it wouldn't be
checkmate
so a rook is tough it's not easy to meet
with a rook so if black plays King here
and lines up the Kings then this is
checkmate but if you play here right
away
even though I can't I guess this Plex
turn ok so then that's checkmate hooray
[Music]
well you could try to go off the board
but you have to be a grandmaster did you
Oh see I did it okay but in real life
you can't do it and you can't move your
King anywhere I won't let me darn
I'm trying and all that means no because
it's not still me because you're in
check if you're in check you're never in
stalemate that's somebody wrote that
down once so stalemate is the same as
checkmate and there's one difference
check me you're in check stalemate
you're never in check so checkmate here
in Shaq and you have no legal move still
me
you have no legal move but you're not in
check ok and if you've played checkers
before then the rules are different if
you get still mated you lose in checkers
if you get still made it in chess it's a
draw ok which actually actually makes
sense though yes
that would be another way to win I agree
with that
okay so when you have a king in a ruck
your opponent doesn't want to play King
here because your opponent doesn't want
to get mated I assume so your opponent
runs away from your king and then you
chase it by the way the stalemate that
hardly ever happens is this one that's
stalemate don't do that but okay that's
hard to do but that's it that's like we
only steal me with a rook it's hard to
steal me with a truck but there it is
okay
so you're gonna keep and now the King
can't keep going because there's no more
chessboard so the King has to go here we
got our opposition and then checkmate if
you had a queen this would be checkmate
is that checkmate with a ruck now cuz
the King can go sideways and again while
the King moves sideways yeah okay and
also a lot of kids for some reason they
move their King next to the king and say
checkmate now if you watch TV and that's
all you do then what you have computers
and I forgot but when you watch TV
there's a commercial for something
what's the commercial for I didn't get
that part I just saw that well I don't
know what the commercial is about but
there's a commercial that's on every
five seconds on every channel where a
guy's playing chess I think it's for
like car insurance or something anyway
and then and then he's like really
thinking and then he and then he takes
the what's it for this is energy drink
yeah I don't know what the commercials
for all I know is Zoom Zoom Zoom I don't
know anything else anyway so so in the
gate in the commercial the guy takes his
opponents King because he's trying
really hard
okay very suspicious because we don't do
that okay but in the commercial they do
okay so let's go back even though we
can't go back we're gonna go back anyway
by using trickery and we're going back
okay here's a good position to start
this is actually pretty hard so you're
white is it white Stern yeah you're if
this was a queen it's pretty easy where
the rook is pretty hard okay so
what you want to do is cut off the board
so the board doesn't exist okay you like
to take scissors and cut the board then
the guy can't move his king there
because there's no chess board and you
can actually do that with a rock you can
cut the board off so the board doesn't
exist
so yeah so let's play this smooth that
means the rest of the game the black
King can't go here can it but can't go
there then it can't go here which means
it can go here that part of the board
doesn't exist and we can actually keep
doing that yeah I need yeah and at some
point he's gonna go to a back row and
then we're gonna checkmate him okay
yeah and now like where do I go I can
either go to the second-ranked here or
the second-ranked here that's
unfortunate let's go to the
second-ranked here so turn your head
sideways that's the second-ranked
otherwise the four thing if you're
looking straight now we just make a move
like this and black has to cry when you
have a king in a rook you make a lot of
waiting moves that don't do anything
because then black has to move into a
bad position black either moves to the
back rank which he doesn't want to do or
he lines up the Kings which he doesn't
want to do and then you check him to the
back rank pray then we're almost now a
lot of people would go here and now
White has checkmate in two moves and
there's six answers is that enough
answers it's basically all six of these
squares okay this one's the closest and
then checkmate if you don't like that
checkmate you could move your rook
really far away and if the King goes
here you go checkmate and usually what
happens is the King runs away and you
chase him and the board runs out of room
and then he has to line the king up and
you checkmate
wait is king here check me now how about
rook here no no no that's checkmate okay
and you'll notice I hardly ever put
black in check when you don't know how
to meet with a rook you don't know what
you're doing then you go check check
check check that means you don't know
what you're doing what you're trying to
do
is force the black king the so one of
the back rows here then you can put them
in check me just like with just like why
was it funny diagonal there just like
with a queen if every move you make is
check you're not doing it right okay
like in this position if it was White's
move this check would be terrible
because blunt you want black to go back
here okay
so black wants to go up here so forcing
the King up here that doesn't help you
so I move my King up or I would move my
rook here too
yeah he either ways good they're all
good but the worst is like just checking
randomly like I'll just check every move
yeah you want to move your king you're
the other guy's King so you have two
against one
now it's very rare that you have king
and rook versus king that would be a
really close game one side has a rook
one side has nothing most games are some
mismatches where you're beating up on
somebody so you have a queen or two
queens or they have a queen or two
queens and they're beating up on you
that would be a really close game okay
and the tough move to play in a position
like this is is to not move at all if
you move King here well I guess I can't
but I can trick the computer so I can
still do it let's see did I do it yeah I
did it okay
if you play King here they play King
here and you play King here okay and
then you both start laughing that that's
not how you check me okay when you want
the Kings to be in a straight line like
this or like this in a straight line if
you're the one trying to win and you
move the King in a straight line your
opponent will move away because they
have to so don't do that you want the
other person to move in a straight line
then you'll checkmate how do you do that
not by doing this I'm moving your King
back and from that you just make a rook
move like here and you go AHA now it's
your move but don't say AHA okay now if
they go here you checkmate and if they
go here you chase them and and then you
and then you check me
and I'll show you one more thing and
then okay you're white in this position
right well again if you oppose Kings
they're going to move their King away
you want the other guy to oppose Kings
but if the guy moves this King away from
your king he's going to attack your ruck
so I move my rook over here now he's not
going to attack my ruck he can try to
attack my rook but I'll check made him
first so if you want to attack my rook
you want to go here but that's illegal
so you go here first
checkmate okay so you run away and I
chase you and the chase always ends in
the corner if you don't want to go in
the corner you can get checkmated
quicker okay but you run in the corner
and now and now you're forced to go here
and then checkmate I hate when that
happens I want some white then I like it
and I heard in the last class with the
teeny-tiny kids they're like this big
they were in some movie I saw Honey I
Shrunk my chess opponent okay
they beat the guy who is teaching so
they kicked that guy out put me in is
that what happened something like that
happened that was like half right okay
now the most interesting end games
aren't these because I win these two
easily the most interesting are King and
pawn in games clear yeah like you have a
king and a pawn and your opponent has a
king okay so when you have a pawn in the
endgame
you would like to go all the way to the
end and make what Queen okay or in
checkers a king now in the endgame
there's three things that are better
than the opening in the opening you want
your King to be safe so you castle you
never move your king up and you surround
your king with pieces in the opening you
never put your pawn on the back row
because your pawn doesn't let you in the
opening your ricks are in the corner and
they never do anything you've made like
ten moves and your rooks are still in
the corner right then you're like ah
those rooks
that's that's the horse of a different
color okay now in the endgame it's the
opposite your rooks are crushing your
opponent your King walks up the board
and your pawns become Queens although
your pawns only become Queens when you
get the Grandmaster title then your
pawns all become Queens okay so in this
position I want my pawn to become a
queen and then I'll meet with the Queen
because I just learned how to do that I
just learned a few minutes ago okay and
if you have the black pieces you don't
want the guy to make a queen so you stop
them so the question is who's going to
be successful that depends on how well
you play now if the king is in front of
the pawn which it is here then it should
be a draw okay that's going to be a draw
because of stalemate black just keeps
his King in front white can't move his
king up he can try to and then black
always keeps his King in front of the
pawn and in front of the King black only
moves sideways in forwards here black
can't move sideways or forward it's
illegal so you have to move back and use
three choices this is the key position
in all of chess one move draws in two
moves lose
[Music]
[Music]
strangely that was correct are you
surprised
I am yeah is it Those like what okay so
you want to move to the white square and
the reason is when black moves his King
up you want to get the opposition
opposes King and this way you're ready
for everything let's go that way
we oppose Kings the King can't move up
it won't let me man if my King could
move up I would win so the pawn has to
check the King has to go here to save
the pawn and that's called so who wins
nobody or white could try the other way
which is the exact same thing and then
and then it's a different same stalemate
stalemate now let's say black makes a
mistake and goes diagonal to here
okay now blacks actually losing white
goes here black has to go here and then
white black has to give way and white
makes a queen
yay and then white should win because I
taught you that earlier so in this
position you want to move your King back
and forth that's easy to remember
you always go back and you always go up
so if your opponent lets you go up you
go up and then you go back and then you
go up that's hard to remember isn't it
okay now what a lot of kids do here is
they see the King over here and they're
like all opposition now that loses you
have to go back in the forest so you go
here and then if he goes or you get
opposition and in fact this is a draw
when the King is in front of the pawn so
this King is in front of this pawn it's
a draw if we switch the Kings then
sometimes white wins and then you'll be
winning there's a rule if you have King
and pawn versus King both sides want
their King in front of the pawn you
always want to move your king up not
your pawn move your pawn up the guy I'll
take it
if you move your King up then your king
can escort the pawn home
so for example if the president's
driving in a car and they wants a car to
be safe do the Secret Service are they a
mile behind the car are they in front of
the car the answer answer is both but
but they're not they're not behind the
car and then the front of the car is not
protected they don't do that okay they
got everywhere protected so if you want
to make a queen with this pawn you got
to hit the white king you got to get
over there and help otherwise it's going
to be a stalemate so what we can do is
we can do the switcheroo you guys ever
done the switcheroo okay we sweet we put
the white king here lots of white kings
okay now if a Grand Master walked in and
I said to him is this a win or a draw
what would he say so far nobody has the
right answer nobody nobody has the right
answer yeah what's the right answer
what well both is the radience herb you
don't know why he would say I have a
question whose turn is it and then when
I told me whose turn it was then he'd
give the right answer okay so if it's
White's turn to move it's a draw it's
blacks turn to move black loses because
this is the opposition both sides have a
perfect position
so if white moves black just follows
white and why can't do anything and then
eventually White's going to give up
trying to move his king forward he's
going to move his pawn forward and we
already saw this remember the stalemate
we just looked at stalemate okay on the
other hand if it's blacks turn to move
which I can do by tricking the computer
I can push black to move that was easy
yeah now blacks losing because wherever
black goes white it's gonna move his
king up
there's no way black can move the king
and stop all those moves unless he's
reading it right now he'd have to pick
his king up and put it back in the same
place I would do that if I was
playing but then the director would yell
at me okay so let's say we go to the
side white goes up and then we go here
and now the King protects all these
important squares so the pond just
Queens the next four moves are all pawn
moves all of them and then white makes a
queen and white wins because White's
king is helping out his pawn white wants
to move his King up so both sides want
their King in front of the pawn and if
it's blacks turn to move your black
loses because white gets to move his
King way up and help his pawn out and if
it's White's turn to move it's a draw
because then why can't move his King up
it's illegal yeah I guess I flipped
board by accident that was funny okay
now I know how to flip for without even
trying before I try and I can't do it
so trying is the first step to failure
can't fail as you try okay
so yeah what so let me ask you this
question where should white move his
King here there's a lot of possibilities
right where should white move his King
yes
d6 then White's winning hooray also King
d5 White's winning but we won't tell on
that okay and then yeah there's the the
king is escorting the pawn yeah I hate
when that happens
unless I'm white then I like it okay and
then when you make a queen you win now
what are the difference what are the
differences between the opening and the
endgame in the opening you guys get
lessons every day they're like get your
pieces off the back row Castle don't
make 27 pawn moves in a row play in the
center and then you guys don't do that
but people tell you to do it okay in the
endgame you can't be like getting your
pieces off the back row there's no
pieces and then on the back row anyway
right so the endgame is different in the
endgame you want your king to be act if
you want your King to go take stuff you
want to promote your pawns to Queens in
the endgame sometimes you have a lot of
pawns that can become Queens in the
opening your pawns can't become Queens
because there's eight
house of pieces walking them your
opponent doesn't want you do that and
your rucks want to get really active in
the endgame because they start in the
corner and they can't move in the
endgame they want to go to the seventh
rank and I'm going to tell you why the
seventh rank is a secret it's a secret
everybody knows okay so let's get a
random endgame that I made up okay
here's a random rook and pawn endgame
both sides have the same pawns okay so
should be a draw because both sides have
the same pawns now if it's White's turn
the move White has two advantages
White's not gonna get mated on the back
row because White has a square for his
King and black will get made on the back
row if blacks rook leaves it'll be
checkmated the other advantage is it's
White's turn so white goes to the
seventh rank that's where all the black
pawns are and now blacks King can't move
up black okay so black doesn't want to
lose any pawns of black goes here and
now white can move his King up the board
and black can't do anything if black
moves his rook he'll lose his pawn if
black moves his King this way then he'll
lose this pawn
so black should probably play like G
sitting outside his turn if black plays
g6 and then tries to move his King up he
still can't go here because he loses
pawn so the white rook is much better
than the black rook it's on the seventh
rank and you want your rooks on the
seventh rank of the endgame then your
opponent can't do anything now what's it
now what a lot of kids do unfortunately
and Bensimon for example is they like to
put their opponent in check nothing is
more fun than putting your pawn in check
right so in this position they play rook
here check yay then their opponent goes
here and they're like oh okay well black
wants to move his King up and black
doesn't want all his pawns attacked so
white should put the rook on this
Frank actually this check is a good
start then the seventh ranked seventh
rings great that's where all your
opponent's pawn start out right now
let's imagine a situation where your
opponent moved all their pawns who knows
I don't know how they did it but they
did it they moved all their pawns and
they have this position your rook is
still good on the seventh rank it
doesn't attack any pawns but it keeps
the black King from moving up it's sort
of like king and rook versus king the
King can't move up so White's King can
move up and blacks King is stuck so the
seventh rank even if there's no pawns is
still good because you're stopping the
opponent's king from moving and the
thing that I see a lot okay it's black
smooth fire okay this is the worst if
you had white in this position and you
go Jack and Shaq then you're just
helping black move his king of the board
and you could have just stopped them
completely now black has the advantage
because blacks rook is good and his King
is better so you don't want to check
your opponent's king of the board in the
endgame you want to check your
opponent's kennethware in the opening
and if your king is walking up the board
in the opening you're gonna get
checkmated because your opponent has a
lot of pieces here Black's not gonna get
checkmated if somebody was gonna win
this endgame why would they win what
would the winning idea be are you gonna
check me with a rook against another
rook that seems difficult yes you would
get a pawn all the way to the end and
get a queen if nobody ever gets a queen
it's probably going to be a draw if
somebody gets a queen they'll probably
win so you want pawns to become Queens
here no pawns are becoming Queens so
nobody's winning yet so you want in the
endgame when there's very few pieces
left you want pawns to become Queens
because a rooks not going to be the rook
once your opponent gives the rook away
for nothing then a rook will be nothing
so but if you have if your pawn becomes
a queen then you'll win and sometimes
you'll even sacrifice material to do
that you'll give a night away because
you want to make a queen Queens better
than the night so you're trying to
promote your pawn but there's something
in the way and you're like ah okay
promote my pawn you sacrifice a knight
you sacrifice a Bishop maybe then your
pawn becomes a queen then you're like
okay cool
now as all of you know and when I say
all of you know probably none of you do
you can promote a pawn to different
things but usually it's a queen but
occasionally something else yeah King
here that's right yeah that's right is
it white yeah okay now in this position
the normal move is you take the rook and
make a queen black takes and then it
should be a draw because it's Queen and
two pawns against Queen and two pawns
and if you take this pawn then you get
checkmated so don't take that pawn okay
so that's probably a draw but actually
white can win with the craziest thing
you've ever seen in your life then you
win okay and this has to do with under
promotion yeah like when I go to a job
after I'm there for about two three
weeks I'm under promoted yay yes it is
Queen takes a seven you sacrifice your
queen black only has one legal move so
you should play it okay and then the
King is not protecting the rook anymore
so if you make a queen you still get
checkmated so don't do that but you can
promote to something else look look how
it gives me a choice the night the night
and then whites doing quite well because
he's forking and checking you have to go
out a check I can't make as it won't let
me
I keep trying though okay and then I and
then White has a night and two pawns and
black has one pawn so white sacrifices
Queen under promoted to a fork forking
the King and Queen happens every day now
that only happens in puzzles and real
games you never get to do that they
don't let me I'm under promoted in real
games but it's really rare I've played
several thousand games I've under
promoted like six times that promotes to
a queen about
20,000 times because queens are good
right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]